- If we're being honest,
many companies, especially
large complex companies,
don't really have strategies.
They have goals, mission
statements, vision statements,
long-term plans, all sorts of budgets.
They have forecasts.
People will call them strategies,
but they really are not.
At the core, strategy is about focus.
It's about making choices,
making trade-offs.
Large, complex organizations
don't really focus their resources.
Instead, they pursue
multiple goals at once
hoping that if they do enough things,
some of them will succeed.
So, in a course on strategy,
we should begin by trying to
clear up some of the confusion
around what strategy is.
Let's begin by discussing
what strategy is not.
Strategy is not a formula or a model dump.
Strategy is not a future forecast
no matter how sophisticated
the data analytics are.
Strategy is not a detailed
plan or program of instruction.
It's not a template, or
a list of things to do.
Strategy is not a label
that enhances the importance
of a decision or a functional plan.
For example, attaching
the word strategy to price
does not make a price
strategy a real strategy.
Cutting or lowering prices is
just that, lowering prices.
Developing a competitive,
low-cost strategy
is fundamentally different
from cutting prices,
and calling it a price strategy.
Similarly, getting people
to do data analytics
is not an IT strategy.
Strategy is not fluff, gibberish,
big fancy words masquerading
as strategic concepts.
So, what is strategy?
Let's give the concept of
strategy some definition.
A strategy is an integrated, overarching,
externally oriented concept
of how a firm will achieve its objectives.
It is a unifying theme that
gives coherence and direction
to the actions and
decisions of an individual
or an organization.
The captains in Admiral Nelson's Navy
didn't have cell phones,
nor did they have sophisticated
forms of communication
to coordinate their naval battle actions.
What they had was a simple guiding policy
of breaking the coherence
of the Spanish and French naval formation,
and turning the naval battle
into a series of one-on-one,
ship-to-ship sea battles.
Nelson's strategy required every captain
to work independently,
making literally dozens
and dozens of decisions
that combined to produce coherent action,
and a startling naval victory.
A competitive strategy is a game plan,
a cohesive overall approach
that explains how the
firm will beat its rivals,
and earn superior returns
on its investments.
Strategies are needed when a
firm faces a strategic issue,
a new opportunity, or a new challenge.
So, what makes an issue strategic?
First of all, strategic
issues are important.
They can be any managerial
decision or action
which affects the success,
and even survival,
of a business enterprise.
They are, to say, life
and death decisions.
Second, they affect the
organization as a whole.
They require what we refer to
as a general manager's point of view.
Opportunities and problems
need to be addressed
from an integrated,
cross-functional perspective.
Third, they can be apparent,
or below the surface.
But, they have real implications
for the long-term success
or even survival of the firm.
Fourth, strategic issues
can be internal or external.
They can be internal cultural issues,
or they can be needing to
deal with a new technology,
or a new competitor.
All strategic decisions require choice.
If there is no need for a trade off,
then the decision is not truly strategic.
We simply do both things.
Strategic decisions involve
significant commitments
of resources, time, or money
that are often irreversible,
or they are not easily
reversible in the short run.
Investments need to be made today
before their outcomes are known.
It's also important to remember
that a strategic issue is
a problem or a challenge.
It is not an alternative or a solution.
It is not about deciding
between different options.
It is the deep, careful thinking
about the complexities of a situation,
and defining a guiding policy
to overcome the problem,
or to take advantage of an opportunity.